مشاهدينا سننتقل الان لمتابعه الخبر الذي
ورد قبل قليل من مدينه جده والمتعلق
باتفاق اعلان المبادئ الذي تم توقيع عليه
بين
الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع اثرى المفاوضات
المستمره منذ ايام في جده في اعقاب
الاشتباكات
التي دامت اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع بين
الجانبين اي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع من جده معنا مراسل الجزيره بدر
ربيعان لوضعنا في تفاصيل هذا الاتفاق بين
الجيش والدعم السريع بدر
نعم حسن حقيقه يعني
من المشاورات
التمهيديه بطرف النزاع في السودان يمكن ان
نجبلها في اعلان جدا الذي لم تعلن عن
حقيقه وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه بشكل رسمي
حتى اللحظه ولكن وفقا لمصادر نتحدث عن اهم
النقابه التي وردت في هذا الاعلان هي
الانتقال النزاع المسلح المنفرد الى مرحله
نجاح منضبط عبر عدم استهداف المدنيين ما
في تبادل اطلاق النار ايضا عدم
السماح بالتدخل الاجنبي بحمايه سيارات
الانقاذ الطبي والمقرات وعدم عرقله حركه
المسار مسار انقاذ الطبي او تحويل المقرات
الطبيه الى فترات عسكريه ايضا
بعدم اطلاق النيران من مناطق ذات كثافه
مدنيه نتحدث عن عن تفاصيل ربما في عمليه
العسكريه يتجه على الارض ايضا الالتزام
بمبادئ قانون الدوله الانساني اضافه الى
الق انون الدولي لحمايه حقوق الانسان
عن عمليه اخفاء قصير المدنيين
المحافظه على مسار العمليات الانسانيه
لتجري في السودان وتقوم بها عده جهات
مختلفه في ولايه السودان نتحدث عن عمليات
الاجلال نتحدث عن عمليات الذات الطابعه
الانساني
المنظمات الانسانيه وكذلك جهاز فالاشاره
بوضوح الى ان قياده المبادره لهذا الاعلان
كانت مشتركه بين السعوديه وامريكا بوضوح
هذا يمكن اجمال ابرز ما ما ورد في هذا
الاعلان حتى اللحظه ولم يصدر بيان رسمي من
قبل بدر يعني كما كما نفهم من النقاط التي
ذكرتها في هذا الاعلان هو اعلان لا يتحدث
عن هدنه لا يتحدث عن وقت لاطلاق النار هو
اعلان يحيد المدنيين في الاصل
واذا اذا صح التعبير كانه
ينظم ويضع مبادئ
للاقتتال ولكن تحييد المدنيين
نعم
مصالح وسلامه الشعب السوداني التزام ضمان
حمايه المدنيين نعم هو وبالتالي
يضع طرح حمايه المدنيين
الارض ضبطها بشكل واضح من خلال الاتجاه
مبادئين قوات الدعم السريع وايضا الجيش
السوداني يتحدث عن ايضا مسؤوليه كلا
الطرفين بالاحترام القانوني
واضح ان
العمليه العمليه العسكريه تجري على الارض
من بنزاع مسلح
منضبط على الاقل يلتزم فيه السرطان
بالحفاظ على الضوابط الانسانيه
بعدم الدخول وتحديد المدنيين
المسار الانقاذ والعمليات الانسانيه تجعل
الارض مما يتعلق بالاجلاء الطبي عمليات
الاجلاء الى ما اذا الى ما الى ذلك نتحدث
ايضا يعني
الالتزامات هي
السماح بمرور امن المدنيين لمهاجمه مناطق
الاعمال العدائيه على اساس طوع اذا هو
يجمل ويضبط العمليه العسكريه على الارض
يمكن القول بهذا الاتجاه حقيقه الحسن
لكن كما كما ذكرت لم يصدر بيان رسمي من
الخارجيه السعوديه
بهذا المعنى يعني هل سيكون هناك ترتيب
معين كيف سيتم الاعلان رسميا عن هذا توقيع
هل من معلومات او عن هذا
الاتفاق اتفاق المبادئ هل هناك سيناريو
معين مطروح
من المفترض ان يصدر بيان دليل من وزاره
الخارجيه على موقعها في تويتر وايضا على
وكاله الانباء السعوديه البيان
بعد التوقيع الطرفين عليه هو بيلتزم
باعطاء الاولويه
تحقيق وقت اطلاق نار قصيره لتسهيل توصيل
المساعده الانسانيه وايضا استعاده الخدمات
الاساسيه وكذلك يعني يلتزم الاعلان هذا
بجدوله مناقشات الموسعه اللاحقه لتحقيق
وقف دائم الاعمال اياه كما ذكرت سيصدر
بيان رسمي ولكن مجمل ما سيكون في هذا
البيان هو ما تحدثنا عن من خلال هذه
النقاط التي ذكرناها قبل قليل فقط هو ضبط
العمليه العسكريه على الارض الالتزام من
كلا الطرفين
بتوفيل ممرات انسانيه لعمليات الاجلاء
وايضا كذلك العمليات
الانسانيه بعمومها الطبيه العمليات
الانسانيه في مجبل الولايات السودان لكن
لا يوجد اعلان رسمي عن هدنه لا يوجد اعلان
رسمي عن
توقيع اتفاقيه بهدف تجنيب
المزيد من الاعمال العسكريه خلافه المقبله
هو فقط التزام مبادئ واعلان عن عن التزام
بجانب الاعمال الانسانيه وضبط العمليه
على كل هذا الامر لم يكن لم يكن مفاجئا
باعتبار ان الوفد وفد الجيش السوداني حتى
عندما غادر الى جده غادر واعلن المتحدث
باسم الجيش ان
المفاوضات لا تتعلق بالتفاوض على وقف
اطلاق نار فقط على قضايا انسانيه وممرات
امنه وهذا ما يبدو الذي حصل في
اعلان المبادئ الذي ذكرته والذي تم
الاتفاق عليه بدر اذا اذا عدنا الى هذه
المفاوضات هل يمكن القول انها الان قد
انتهت والوفود سوف تغادر ولن يكون هناك
مرحله ثانيه من التفاوض في
يعني في الايام المقبله
الحقيقه السعوديه وامريكا ملتزمه بان
تتوسع هذه المبادره قامت بها بجمع الطرفين
على طاوله واحده هنا في جده وبالتالي
عمليه المفاوضات
ستستمر من المؤكد سيكون هناك مباحثات
المبادره التي قامت بها السعوديه وامريكا
كانت تستهدف الى جمع مع طاوله واحده ومن
ثم ترقيه هذه المواحدات ما سمنه وسمته
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه بالالمباحثات
التمهيديه مرحله مفاوضات
بهدف الوصول الى حل وملامح طريق الخروج من
هذه الازمه على كافه الاصعده الانسانيه
وسياسيه والعسكريه وبالتالي
ان تغلق في هذه المرحله بالتاكيد السعوديه
وامريكا بهذه نحو ايجاد مخرج وايجاد حلول
لهذه الازمه عبر الجلوس معك مع طفيها على
طاوله الان هي نجحت في جلب الطرفين على
طاوله واحده
طرفين من وايضا شروط بهدف على الاقل تاسيس
ارضيه للجلوس على على طاوله واحده ومن ثم
التوافق حول نقاط يتم على الرسم من خلالها
ملامح مستقبل هذه الحربه تجري على الارض
وبالتالي لن تتوقف هذه المباحثات وفقا
للاعلان ايضا هناك بند من البنود يتحدث عن
المباحثات ستكون مستمره وهناك اولويه
لمناقشات بهدف وقف اطلاق وقف بارتباط نار
قصير وهذا ما تسعى اليه
المبادره حقيقه منذ ان بدات ومنذ ان
اشتعلت هذه الازمه منذ اربعه اسابيع
تقريبا حتى اللحظه شكرا لك بدر ربيعان
مراسل الجزيره احدثنا من مدينه جده